the public in the private lives of
Britain's royal family have captivated
the world for generations
last month 90 year old queen elizabeth
ii made history is the longest-serving
British monarch with a 65 year range her
son Prince Charles now holds the record
is the longest waiting heir to the
British throne Prince Charles the
passions and paradoxes of an improbable
life what a title is the first major
biography of Charles in more than 20
years it sheds new light on the defining
moments that shaped the future King
author Sally Bedell Smith joins us at
the table to discuss welcome thank you
this wonder that we build here see you
all use yeah I was struck by the phrase
in your book that you used a lot poor
Charles is what a lot of people used to
say to Maz he was growing up in his
teenage years and now that he's sitting
waiting to be queen what do you mean
Kings how do I get that wrong King it
was just an incredibly sensitive child
yeah and and he is somebody who's really
caught between two worlds he was he was
brought up in this incredibly
traditional environment he went out it
just into outside the palace for school
for the first time but he had everything
was set up for him and so he's caught
between the very traditional upbringing
of his mother who's you know who is so
popular and then he's got the more
modern children William and Harry so
he's kind of the man in the middle and
he's always been kind of overshadowed by
both and when I started working on this
book five years ago he seemed to be this
kind of blurry figure in the background
and he seemed ready to be looked at with
a you know with a magnifying glass to
really see what makes him tick did he
cooperate he did they gave me a lot of
cooperation it's not an official
biography but that's fine because I like
to be independent but I was able to
travel to Sri Lanka and to Malta to see
him at work to visit all of his the
places he's most proud of he's built a
model town in in Dorset that is
fascinating because there are poor
people and rich people living
side-by-side it's got a very
advanced fuel plant that uses plant ways
to produce renewable energy so that's
part of the dichotomy I mean he is
somebody who is like Lord Grantham and
Downton Abbey he's still dressed by a
valid everyday but he was one of the
pioneers of green energy so I found him
there you get the paradoxes and and he's
also just and he's a real renaissance
man I was you know having written about
the Queen having written about his first
wife Diana I was astonished at the range
of his of his of his interests and and
also accomplishments I mean who knew
he's rebuilt an old quarter of Kabul
Afghanistan with 65 buildings
rehabilitated and an institute of
traditional art but still people always
want to know Sally about him and
Princess Diana yes you know because it
seems so troubled as you're right from
the very start it was a troubled
relationship and certainly even on their
wedding day chinks in the armor before
they tied the knot even before they you
know the six months before they they
actually walked down the aisle I mean
they the astonishing thing that I found
out was that they'd only been together
for 12 times before he proposed to her
he made up they made a promise that he
was going to be married by the age of 30
obviously his role was to produce the
next heir that was important the press
was on his back his furniture on he felt
terrible pressure so he met somebody who
looked on paper she was from a very
aristocratic family but he didn't know
that she had a very sort of troubled
emotional history from the time she was
really 6 years old and her parents had a
really ugly divorce and and so they
didn't have the time to get to know each
other to develop a mature relationship
say the way Kate and William did they
were able to live together for eight
years before they got married he
scarcely knew Diana there was a 12-year
age gap they had very little if anything
in common and and he was in love with
Camilla and he was in love with Camilla
and that's a whole backstory of this
book I mean Camilla his more than
40-year love for Camilla is kind of at
the heart of the book they he fell madly
in love with her in 19
seventy-two and then he went off to the
Navy expecting her to wait for him but
she was not appropriate because she
she'd had a lot of romances one what are
you from ISM is he was well navigated
and she that was not that was the
traditional part she he was expected to
marry a virginal girl and I Anna a sweet
character girl who we could put on a
pedestal and that's what Diana was and
even though he was in love with Camilla
and as you said on the night of their
the night the eve of their wedding
Diana was so tied up and not she was she
was violently ill staying with her
sister and he was looking out the
windows of Buckingham Palace and his
Vallot walked up to him and said sir why
are you crying and he said can you be in
can you be in love with two women at the
same time so he was sort of tormented
about it from the beginning yeah yes
somebody so what about her though I mean
you wrote a book about Diana yes she was
mad in love with him or she was she
really sort of went after him I mean she
she had a kind of idealized vision of
what it would like be like to be a
princess or step-grandmother with
Barbara Cartland who wrote all these you
know these fantastical novels but she
was she was crazy about him and and to
be there's no there was nobody's fault
they were thrown together they were a
mismatch and it was just trouble you
know ready to be king yeah I believe hey
mom I bet he is ready to be king I mean
one of the fascinating things I found
out is that since 2008 he has been under
a very close tutorial by the Queen's
senior private secretary sort of getting
him through this transition he for his
whole life he's been able to do what he
wanted to do basically to be a
charitable entrepreneur to start all
these things he's a great father he's a
mighty father that was one of the real
things that I've discovered in his book
the longest air in waiting long waiting
but you know what he will not have a
long reign but he will be remembered for
a lot of good accomplishments well he
was pretty
he's 68 yeah I got a new phrase thank
you baby you guys well navigated don't
want to be that okay well navigated girl
okay okay that's a whole nother country
yeah I know
well navigator and navigate well yes
that's right know how to drive that
train beyond